Professor Langdon
Hammer: I was wanting to
carry over more Williams today.
Poor Williams,
he only got a day,
like Langston Hughes,
but it's hard to give everybody
their day.
And I think on reflection I'd
rather give two full lectures to
Marianne Moore because first of
all, she's a difficult poet.
"Oh good," you're saying,
"as opposed to all these other
people."
She's difficult in a different
way, and in some ways she
doesn't seem difficult,
as you get started,
but she's idiosyncratic and I'd
like to give her a chance to get
your attention and give you a
chance to learn how to read her.
It also strikes me that we
haven't read a lot of women
poets in this course,
have we?
We've read H.D.,
but that's really about it so
far.
The giants of modern poetry,
they're men:
Yeats, Eliot and company.
Moore has a claim to stature
like theirs.
I think she is a remarkable
poet, and one who interestingly,
I think, has had as much or
perhaps even more practical
influence and effect over the
development of poetry since
modernism,
as much or more than any of the
poets we've been reading.
The general question of the
position of women and of women
poets in modern poetry is
interesting and important,
and an important context for
thinking about Moore.
Women in the modernist literary
culture that we've been studying
are identified very frequently
with popular and gentile forms
of writing and taste;
think about Hart Crane
complaining to Harriet Monroe,
the editor of Poetry
magazine, as if she's just too
square to get it.
This is not an unusual attitude.
Women are associated to a
degree with political writing of
the period, certain kinds of
experimental writing,
and also above all with the
legacy of the nineteenth-century
poetess.
James Joyce said The Waste
Land "ended the idea of
poetry for ladies";
this is its achievement.
Poor ladies!
Well, you maybe get the idea in
Joyce's comment that here was a
poem that broke with a
nineteenth-century culture of
poetry that was in certain ways
feminized,
at least as imagined here by
Joyce and certainly by other
modern poets.
At the same time you can think
about the very rich and
complicated role of women in
The Waste Land in order
to get some sense of the
complexity of the position of
women in modern poetry in
general.
Think of the ways in which
Eliot as a poet draws on female
speakers and female voices and,
you might say,
even aspires to sound like
Isolde or Philomel or,
well, one of his own inventions
in "The Fire Sermon."
In general, you could say that
the modern poets we've been
reading aggressively and
self-consciously masculinize
poetry,
in particular by trying to
disassociate poetry from what is
commercial, polite,
soft, dreamy,
ideal, leisured – all
qualities and attitudes gendered
in their imagination – and
instead connect poetry to what
is technically rigorous,
advanced, learned,
unsentimental,
hard, and often hard work:
terms that are,
again, clearly gendered.
H.D.
in her own distinctive way is
also doing this,
taking part in this.
Modern poetry wanted to make
poetry culturally central and
powerful, to reposition it,
to achieve for it the power to
define and describe culture.
And this was very often,
as I'm suggesting,
played out in very gendered
terms,
trying to claim for poetry a
set of capacities that were
strongly gendered in these
poets' imaginations.
At the same time this desire,
as I'm saying,
is conflicted and complicated,
and we need only think of
Eliot's case,
but you could look back to
Yeats's relationship to women
speakers, his own complicated
set of identifications with
them, and so on.
How does Marianne Moore fit in
this?
What did it mean for her to be
a modern poet and a woman?
These are questions that I'll
take up today,
first of all addressing this
question specifically of,
well, what did it mean to write
from the position of a woman,
for Moore?
And then I want to go on and
talk about Moore as an American
poet, which she was
self-consciously,
and then to begin to talk about
Moore as a nature poet,
which she also was.
Let's get started by looking at
one of her earliest
publications,
a poem that like many of the
other important early poems by
these poets appeared in
Poetry magazine,
this time I think in 1919;
I'm not sure,
I'll check the date.
I'm talking about the poem
called "A Grave" on page 440.
It's a great poem and it's a
poem that announces a speaker
that sounds like no one else,
and sounds like certainly no
one we have been reading.
Think about "The Seafarer,"
another poem about the sea.
How did that sound?
"Bitter breast-cares have I
abided, nigh on the
night-watch."
You remember Pound's sonorous
and even perhaps ponderous,
heroic Anglo-Saxon alliterative
meter,
which I talked about as,
in Pound's case,
a deliberate and interesting
evasion of iambic pentameter
norms – blank verse as a kind
of model for heroic speech.
Well, so is this,
but it sounds nothing like
that.
It's on the other end of the
spectrum, right?
It sounds like what?
Prose, in certain ways;
a remarkable,
elevated prose,
but prose, prose that uses
words like "consciousness" or
"volition," "however."
When was the last time you saw
a poem that said "however"?
It really announces a speaker
who is using a kind of
expository language.
There are Latinate words.
There's obviously no meter and
rhyme.
At the same time there is a
developed and,
as almost always in Moore,
intricate formal design,
an idiosyncratic formal design
that is operating in the poem,
but almost secretly.
What's it look like on the page?
A lot of long lines, right?
A lot of long lines,
some of which run over.
Well, this, like other Moore
poems, is a poem structured
around counting syllables per
line and counting,
in fact, numbers of lines.
This is not a kind of formal
organization that you hear,
and it's even difficult to see,
but it's an operative one for
her and it's one of the ways in
which she organizes her verse.
It's as if Moore has in some
sense set up her own rules,
clung to them,
and kept them secret.
She doesn't always keep them
secret;
sometimes they're quite
conspicuous and even flashy in
certain poems in their designs.
But here it's quite
inconspicuous.
What you have is a poem that is
made up of two eleven-line
groups, two eleven-line stanzas
or paragraphs,
each beginning with a short
seven-syllable line:
"Man looking into the sea,"
"for their bones have not
lasted."
This is the pattern that
structures the poem.
In all these ways that I'm
describing – the syllable
count, the expository writing,
the Latinate diction,
the self-conscious,
prose-like nature of the
language,
all those semi-colons – this
is poetry that has distanced
itself from traditions of song,
and certainly from
nineteenth-century traditions of
versification.
The form of the poem is,
again, not something you see or
even hear necessarily.
It's there almost as a kind of
absence.
Now, there's also,
wonderfully,
a certain combativeness.
Moore is a combative and
pugnacious poet.
You, again, may not see this
immediately because of the
poem's impersonality,
the way in which it seems to
present itself and the often
intricate forms of syntax or
oblique approach.
But she is a fighter,
and this poem is really a kind
of fighting that we're seeing.
The poem begins in irritation.
It begins as a complaint – a
complaint that's addressed to
whom?
To man;
"Man looking into the sea."
"Man" suggests,
well, maybe humankind.
You think about the people on
the shore in Frost's poem,
"Neither Out Far Nor In Deep,"
who are standing there looking
out at the water.
Well, Moore might be addressing
them.
But I think there's a more
specific and particular "man"
that is the irritant that sets
the poem going:
a man,
the figure of a man who,
like a romantic poet,
has arrogated to himself the
position to take in the view,
to stand like the figure in a
Caspar David Friedrich painting
and gaze into the sublime.
Meanwhile, Moore is somewhere
else.
Where is she?
She's somewhere behind him,
because he's blocked her view:
"Man looking into the sea,
/ taking the view from those
who have as much right to it as
you have to yourself."
Well, "it is human nature to
stand in the middle of a thing,"
she says, trying to make sense
of this.
Moore has a couple of comments
here that describe the origins
of this poem.
It's the first quotation on
your handout.
She says:
As for "A Grave," it has
a significance apart from the
literal origin [but here is the
literal origin],
which was a man who placed
himself between my mother and
me, and the surf we were
watching from the middle ledge
of rocks on Monhegan Island
after the storm.
("Don't be annoyed," my mother
said.
"It is human nature to stand in
the middle of a thing.")
It is important that,
however, Moore was annoyed.
She was annoyed into poetry,
you could say,
and she took her mother with
her.
The poem is really written from
the perspective of a daughter
and mother, and a daughter with
an intimate relationship to her
mother who absorbs,
here and very often elsewhere
in her poetry,
actual quotations from but even
more importantly a style of
speech and attitude associated
with her mother,
who talks a lot like Dr.
Samuel Johnson or some other
eighteenth-century figure and
moralist like that.
Mrs.
Moore is someone whom Marianne
always identified with herself.
It's significant here that
Moore is using a quotation from
her mother and not acknowledging
it in any particular way,
as if the two women had one
voice and one perspective.
The man who blocks their point
of view, and blocks their point
of view, you could say,
in many senses – their
literal point of view of the
water – but also the point of
view he takes in effect ignores
and suppresses theirs.
He is standing in the posture,
as I suggest,
of a kind of conventional,
romantic visionary staring into
the sea, emblem of infinity.
Well, it might be Hart Crane
writing "At Melville's Tomb,"
although Crane wouldn't write
that poem for a few more years;
and when he did,
incidentally,
he sent it to Marianne Moore,
who was then the editor of
The Dial,
who sent it back and rejected
it.
Moore's poem is,
in fact, as I suggested,
an early poem of hers and an
early act of self-definition
that's quite important in both
the impersonality of the point
of view and yet the insistent
individuality of that point of
view.
Moore's poems are like this.
They seem impersonal and yet
they're at the same time deeply
personal and deeply individual.
Here she celebrates the power
of the sea to resist the
imposition of the observer's
will, or the will of the sailor
or seafarer;
you can even think of Odysseus
or Pound's seafarer.
The sea is "a collector,
quick to return a rapacious
look": i.e.
if you want to take possession
of the sea in some way,
well, don't think you can do
that because this is a grander
force than you and it will take
you up and drown you,
which is what the poem goes on
to describe.
The sea has here the force that
it does in other great poems by
Moore like "The Fish" or
"Sojourn in the Whale."
It seems to stand for death.
It is a grave;
it is a grave in which you
could say a certain idea of
romantic and,
I think, specifically male
subjectivity is overcome and
buried, shown its limits.
In this poem the human,
imagined finally as something
that twists and turns in the
depths,
is converted by natural forces
into a part of the natural world
that it sought through the man's
perspective to dominate.
Moore sent this poem to Pound.
These poets are always sending
their poems to Pound.
He responded with admiration in
that second quotation there,
and he says:
"Thank God,
I think you can be trusted not
to pour out a flood (in the
manner of dear Amy and
Masters),"
who though not a woman was a
sentimental regionalist and not
an international modernist.
Pound is approving of Moore
here.
He approves that she does not
gush, she does not emote.
She has not written a
sentimental poem.
In fact, in certain ways she's
written an anti-sentimental
poem.
I think it's important that
Moore's rhetorical choices have
prevented her from doing so,
that the poem has the kind of
formal self-discipline it does.
Again, these are aspects of
restraint in the poetry.
Moore is dry in all respects.
At the same time,
these are modernist values,
values that Pound would
describe in his Imagist
manifesto and elsewhere.
At the same time,
Moore gets her dryness not by
disavowing femininity or
suppressing it or attacking it,
as one of her peers might have.
She does it,
rather, specifically in this
act of challenging "man."
Let me look with you at the
letter that Moore wrote to Pound
in response that acts as a kind
of, now, letter of introduction.
And it has a lot of interesting
things in it and it's probably a
good introduction to who she is
for us, too.
She says:
I was born in 1887 and
brought up in the home of my
grandfather, a clergyman of the
Presbyterian church.
[She comes from a Christian and
God-fearing home.]
I am Irish by descent [and
that's where some of the
combativeness comes from],
possibly Scotch also,
but purely Celtic,
was graduated from Bryn Mawr
[where she knew and befriended
H.D.]… and taught shorthand,
typewriting….
[She's worked for a living.]
In 1916 my mother [Mary Warner
Moore]
and I left home in Carlisle to
be with… [her brother,
a]
Chaplain of the battleship
Rhode Island….
[There's a lot of Christianity
in the family.
She says that she's living with
her mother in New York,
and indeed she would spend the
rest of her life living with her
mother in New York,
in Greenwich Village and in
Brooklyn in a small apartment.]
[C]ontrary to your impression,
I am altogether blond and have
red hair.
[Pound had asked whether she
was Ethiopian,
after he read the poem "Black
Earth": read "Black Earth" and
decide whether Marianne Moore is
an Ethiopian.]
[This is important.
She says]
…Any verse that I have
written, has been an arrangement
of stanzas, each stanza being an
exact duplicate of every other
stanza.
[This is not always true but
she claims it is.]
I have occasionally been at
pains to make an arrangement of
lines and rhymes that I like
repeat itself,
but the form of the original
stanza of anything I have
written has been a matter of
expediency,
hit upon as being approximately
suitable to the subject matter.
The resemblance of my progress
to your beginnings is an
accident….
"I wasn't influenced by you,
Pound, when I started writing
syllabic verse" because Pound
had experimented with this
himself.
There're a couple of ideas here
that are important.
First of all,
that Moore identifies,
as it were, two moments of
creativity involved in the
making of her poems.
One is a moment of spontaneity
and expediency in which lines,
almost like some kind of
channeled speech,
arrive in a certain form,
and then she makes that form in
its contingency and
accidentalness repeat itself.
She goes on and what came by
chance she repeats through will,
through discipline.
This is significant and it's
related to, well,
her originality of form,
which is something that,
as it were, comes to her
naturally and that she builds on
self-consciously and through a
kind of rigorous
self-discipline.
She says then,
"I do not appear."
She meant, "I don't appear in
literary periodicals;
you can't find my poems
anywhere."
But the sentence itself is
wonderfully suggestive and
simple, "I do not appear."
And in fact,
Moore does not appear very much
in her poems.
She is interestingly
backgrounded or even invisible
in her poems,
in the ways that she is in "A
Grave."
And then she says:
I grow less and less
desirous of being published,
produce less and have a strong
feeling for letting alone what
little I do produce.
[And then she continues]
…To capitalize the first word
of every line is rather slavish
[as they do in
nineteenth-century poetry]
and I have substituted small
letters for capitals in the
enclosed versions of the two
poems that you have.
[This is another sort of
distinctive, formal choice Moore
makes, not to capitalize her
first lines--something Williams
does, too.]
…In "A Graveyard," [she goes
on, now talking about the poem
"A Grave" (a grave is better
than a graveyard,
don't you think?)]
[the change]
that I have made is to end of
the line [the very end of the
poem]
as you suggest and for the sake
of symmetry,
have altered the arrangement of
lines in the preceding stanzas.
I realize that by writing
consciousness and volition [this
is the order of the words that
Pound had proposed at the end of
that poem]
emphasis is obtained which is
sacrificed by retaining the
order which I have [that is,
Moore's order,
"volition" and then
"consciousness"],
and I am willing to make the
change,
though I prefer the original
order [which,
in fact, ultimately she
kept].
Let's look at the end of the
poem again.
I'll read from line 20:
Pound said, "Well,
that ending just doesn't quite
do it.
Why don't you switch
'consciousness' and 'volition'?"
With what implication?
That somehow "volition" is more
important than "consciousness,"
that it's the last thing to go
and the most dramatic thing to
lose.
Moore, however,
insists: no,
that's not the case;
it's the other way around.
"Consciousness" is more
important than "volition."
In fact, that's really what
this whole poem is about,
you could say.
Pound wanted the emphasis,
to take Moore's word,
that comes with stressing
"volition" as most important
and,
in fact, volition is nothing
but a kind of expression of
emphasis.
She says no,
"consciousness" is more
important, and as she does,
she emphasizes it.
She introduces another kind of
emphasis, one associated not
specifically with volition so
much as the drama and power of
consciousness,
which she insists on here.
Although Moore's poem could be,
in fact, read as a kind of
rebuke in advance to Hart Crane
and his poem "At Melville's
Tomb,"
Moore, in fact,
got to know and like Crane in
the twenties,
sometimes acting as his editor
when he sent poems to The
Dial for publication.
She turned back "At Melville's
Tomb."
She accepted other poems.
One poem she accepted,
"The Wine Menagerie," was a
poem in quatrains.
She accepted it and then
converted the poem into free
verse and reduced it by half its
size.
Crane accepted it,
accepted this publication along
with ten dollars,
which he needed.
But both Crane and Moore,
like Williams,
were, I think,
self-consciously American
poets,
and their American-ness is
important to how they define
themselves as modern poets.
And there is really in all of
them a certain kind of
combative, cultural nationalism,
which has aesthetic and ethical
implications.
As an example,
let's turn a page back and look
at the poem "England."
Okay, the poem begins here as a
series of national caricatures
and then eventually it will move
from these caricatures,
which suggest ways of life and
also aesthetic dispositions,
ways of doing and thinking
about art, I think;
she'll move from that to talk
about America,
and what is American.
And this is,
you could say,
her real subject here.
And then she will go on and
describe America.
She will go on and contrast
everything that she has just
caricatured in a polite but
essentially negative way,
in each of those cases,
with the American,
and specifically with American
speech and American English.
In other words,
just because Americans who say
"psalm" or "calm" sound like
that instead of "psalm" or
"calm,"
that doesn't mean they're
stupid or that the rest of
America is.
In other words,
if you don't think you can get
poetry in America,
you haven't looked.
It's a wonderful poem.
It's a defense of America and
American creativity,
American language.
It is an attack on Eurocentric,
cultural snobs.
At the same time,
Moore is not only or merely
adding America as one among
other nations.
Rather, America is the locality
where this principle of hers is
honored, a place that
incorporates many other places,
many other cultures,
many other ways of feeling and
thinking and speaking.
This principle,
the idea that inspiration has
never been confined to one
locality,
to one place,
affirms a kind of art that is
not only a matter of high
culture but that is also
vernacular,
regional, heterogeneous,
popular, and includes in it all
kinds of materials.
And you remember the quotation
I pointed to in the first day of
class when I quoted from Moore's
poem "Poetry"?
And she was talking about all
the things that should go in
poetry, even business documents
and school books.
Well, America is a place where
you can put those things in
poems.
This is a proud,
also a comical principle.
It's a democratic principle for
Moore.
Is it maybe also a feminist one?
I think so, in so far as Moore
defines what is American as
specifically and distinctively a
non-hierarchical point of view:
that is,
not so much a woman's point of
view so much as a point of view
that accommodates that of the
woman among others,
within a multiplicity of human
perspectives and,
in fact, non-human
perspectives.
She's serious about including
those cats and dogs.
Why is the poem called
"England"?
By incorporating the title into
the first line of the poem,
Moore makes it seem accidental.
The device foregrounds Moore's
concision and practicality.
Why waste any extra words on
the title?
Pound wants you to use no word
that does not contribute to the
presentation;
okay, then we'll make the title
part of the presentation,
too.
The gesture is also of a piece,
I think, with Moore's distrust
of hierarchy itself.
She says, in effect,
the title is not more important
than the rest of the poem.
It doesn't stand outside it or
above it, it's just part of it;
just as Moore found it slavish
and probably pretentious to
capitalize the first word of
every line of verse.
She wants to,
in that sense,
give dignity to the lowercase,
to non-capital letters.
At the same time Moore is very
wily and clever.
England really is important
here;
that is, it's not merely the
first nation in an arbitrarily
arranged list.
She's defending America and
American English specifically
against the noted superiority of
England and English literature,
where of course Pound,
Eliot, Frost and others had
gone to establish themselves as
poets.
And to this extent she's saying
that the title is not so
important that it stands above
the poem;
England is not so important
that it stands over and above
America.
And in this sense the title,
in fact, turns out to be
important and to give us
important information,
because she's out here to make
England less important and to
deny it its pride of place.
Well, we've got just a few
minutes left to start a long,
difficult and truly marvelous
poem called "An Octopus" that
exemplifies Moore as a nature
poet and exemplifies many of the
distinctive features of her
writing.
Again, this is on page 441.
The title of the poem is the
first line.
We might think that this is
going to be a poem about an
octopus.
Well, not exactly.
In effect, the title is a kind
of riddle that the poem will go
on and explain and expand on.
It's a poem about Mount
Rainier, Mount Rainier where
Moore went with her brother John
in 1922,
that same year that Joyce
published Ulysses and
Eliot ended the idea of poetry
for ladies in The Waste
Land.
The poem involves a kind of
essential contradiction which it
works through in complex ways.
On the one hand,
the mountain that Moore calls
an octopus, that she's writing
about here, is something that is
exactly "other."
It's outside the poet;
it's out there,
like the sea in "A Grave."
It's objectified;
it's something Moore has to
stand apart from,
perhaps try to conquer in the
form of climbing it or conquer
in the form of representing it
in her writing.
And yet, in the course of the
poem, the mountain and its
glacier, which is really the
octopus that she's talking
about,
is something that Moore
identifies herself with,
that comes to look like Moore
in certain ways.
It comes to be identified with
the force of her art.
So, it's both a kind of version
of herself and it's a version of
something "other," too.
The poem is filled with an
extraordinary and bewildering
detail that evokes the natural
world as one of extraordinary
and bewildering detail.
At the same time,
it combines and creates a
fantastic collage of quotation
from a wild variety of sources.
It's hard to know where to
start and stop in this poem,
what its parts are.
It's a question that,
in a sense, Moore is asking
about the mountain itself.
There's in general a kind of
analogy throughout the poem
between the mountain and the
woman who admires it,
whose mind itself can seem
octopus-like,
and reaches out in these long
tentacle-like lines to grasp the
world,
make it her own,
freeze it in poetic language,
even while she's insisting on
the wonderful otherness of the
world.
I won't start reading now at
the end of class but let me say
a couple of further things about
the poem and ask you to re-read
it,
and to, knowing that it's hard,
re-read it more than once,
and maybe not continuously.
It's a very hard poem to read
continuously.
Be sure to read the last
paragraph of it carefully that
begins on page 444.
And let me say something before
we stop about quotation.
You remember that the sea in "A
Grave" mocked the rapacious
collector.
Moore herself was a great
She collected,
among other things,
quotations.
She engrosses them;
she gathers them to her;
she masters her reading.
She brings them into this poem
in, as I say,
a kind of collage.
It gives the poem a kind of,
well, a very strange
polyvocality.
There's many, many voices here.
Think of The Waste Land.
Well, Moore rivals it in this
poem;
many voices that again
democratically allow for,
you could say,
multiple perspectives,
multiple kinds of material.
Unlike The Waste Land,
Moore is not quoting only high
art sources by and large;
well, Eliot has his popular
culture, too,
but we know that it's pretty
much a high culture poem.
Well, Moore is making her poem
out of magazines,
out of a pamphlet from The
National Parks Portfolio,
through her reading in Ruskin
and many other sources.
And it treats those various
texts, you could say,
non-hierarchically,
without a kind of regard to
generic valuations.
She doesn't play off high and
low as Eliot does in "A Game of
Chess," for example.
It makes the sources of poetic
language and of poetry
continuous with ordinary life,
her activities of reading;
and at the same time,
it makes Moore's inspiration
deeply personal,
because who else but Marianne
Moore would have read all this
stuff,
or just these things?
Like Pound, a kind of visionary
scholar who found his muse in a
translated Homer,
Moore, knowing that literary
inspiration is not confined to
any locality,
finds it all over the place in
her reading.
But again, what she's reading
is something different from
Eliot and Pound.
And I'll say more about that
next time.